hey what's up guys my name is ashana
welcome back to the third episode of my
ray tracing series so
last time we spent pretty much the whole
episode talking about math i highly
highly recommend that you take a look at
that episode even if you're not
interested in math because the whole
spirit of the series obviously is
learning how to do absolutely everything
and knowing how everything works and i
think for ray tracing specifically like
this is such a good opportunity to
actually dive deep into how stuff works
on paper map it all out understand it
and then translate that into like code
and see images appear from nothing which
is just super cool now what we're going
to do here today is building on the math
that we actually worked out on paper
last episode we're going to take the
exact same like equations put them into
c plus plus and have them render a
sphere for us the really cool thing
about today's episode is again it's
going to be identical to the stuff that
we did on paper last episode but you're
going to see it kind of applied you know
per pixel to actually render an image
but to make that happen and also make
this a little bit more like sustainable
for the future as our code gets more
complicated i want to dive into the
existing code that we've got and kind of
restructure it a little bit so that we
have basically this concept of a
renderer so over here inside our ray
tracing project let's go ahead and make
a new file and we're going to make two
new files actually called renderer.h and
renderer.cpp now one of my goals with
this series is to keep things as
practical as possible so i don't want to
spend like too much time talking about
like the architecture of a renderer or
anything like that like this is not
really the purpose of this series
we don't have a namespace do we i wanted
i wanted a name for this but i don't
think we have one at the moment so let's
just go ahead and write the class
without a namespace so what i mean is
like i don't really want to put too much
emphasis on like how to design a
renderer you know for a ray tracer or
for a real-time application or whatever
we're going to just keep things as
simple as possible and so the purpose of
this really is it's going to be a class
which holds some context but the idea is
the input is a scene description so we
have like some form of description of
like the 3d world that we're trying to
render and then the output is an image
which holds the pixels that the renderer
has produced which describe that scene
so fundamentally that is like the
purpose of this class and this whole
kind of architecture now at the moment
we really don't have a scene in fact if
we run the current state of our
application it is this we just have a
bunch of random pixels which basically
just proves that we have the ability to
write to a vulcan image and then display
it using imgui every single frame that's
what we're doing here which will look
much better like in real life and not in
a youtube video because of the
compression now because of that we're
not really going to have an input at the
moment but in the future this will take
in like a scene which is going to
basically be something that holds like
the description of our scene like
meaning like all of the objects inside
the scene you know stuff like a light
environment and all of that stuff but
for now we're just going to have a kind
of empty constructor now this
constructor will have stuff in the
future but for now i'm just going to
keep it as just equals default just so
it is there now the real
the real function of this renderer at
the moment is going to be this render
function which literally is going to do
all of the work so the goal here is to
basically render like every pixel that
we have that makes up that viewport that
you saw there which currently has random
pixels now because of the way that this
is going to work the target of that
render function is going to be an actual
image so i'm going to go ahead and
include walnut image and then we're
going to similarly how we like basically
had this image here right i don't really
want to have the image just inside
walnut app.cpp we're going to move this
image to being inside this renderer
class let's also include memory so that
we can use shared pointers and this is
going to be a walnut image now i'm
deliberately like not you know putting
this into the walnut namespace or using
namespace or anything like that i don't
wanna do any of that because i wanted to
be clear like what stuff is from walnut
and what stuff is our stuff that we're
writing as part of this series now going
back though to our main kind of walnut
app class there are obviously a fair few
things here that are really important
for us to take with us for example
before we render we check to see what
the viewport width and height actually
is because we want to be able to render
an image that is the same size as our
viewport and if the viewport size has
changed which is what this function does
over here it will actually create a
brand new image with that new width and
height so that's obviously important
stuff that we need to make sure that we
actually do inside this renderer class
somewhere i think what i'll do for now
is i will just make like a on on resize
function and this on resize function
we're just taking a width and height now
internally it's obviously going to know
the current width and height because an
image actually holds like a width and
height so we can kind of only do the
resize if necessary and to make things a
little bit easier inside this function
where we'll basically do this we can
check to see if the okay well if there's
no image we'll have to create one anyway
but basically we can check to see if
image get width obviously matches the
width and then if like the width hasn't
changed and if the height hasn't changed
then of course we don't need to resize
the image now i have actually added a
new function into walnut called resize
and what this will do if we take a look
at
its implementation you can see that it
will check first of all to see if the
image even needs resizing so it has the
width and height is the width and height
different to what we already have and if
so then it's going to release and then
reallocate that memory so this is like
just a little bit easier to deal with
than having to completely like delete
the image and create a new one one of
the reasons why i really like this
design as well is because the original
kind of image handle so to speak so in
other words like this image like its
pointer doesn't change the object
doesn't change so everything that used
to hold a reference to image like as a
shared pointer obviously still has that
same image because you're not deleting
the object and making a new one which
obviously will have a different like
spot in memory somewhere right you're
actually
keeping that same object and then
changing like the insides basically
which is what we're doing here we're
releasing it like from our gpu memory
and reallocating that gpu memory uh
within this same kind of object so i
like that because it does keep things uh
quite a bit cleaner so ultimately we
need to do this but obviously if we
don't have the image in the first place
then we're going to have to create it
and my plan by the way with this is
we're going to call renderer on resize
first so when we actually render over
here what we're really going to do is
call like renderer
resize and then renderer render so we're
going to see if it needs resizing by
just passing in the viewport width and
height and then we're going to call the
render function which will actually
render into into that image but the only
flaw here is that we do actually still
need to create the image in the first
place if it doesn't exist so i think i
might change this just because resizing
will be the main case if there is an
image then we can just call image resize
like this assuming that it needs to be
resized but again because this does the
check internally i'm going to just call
resize and then obviously if it doesn't
need to it's not going to resize it's
not going to waste time reallocating
memory and then over here
if there is like no image in the first
place then we obviously need to create
it with the width and the height and
then whatever format we want which we'll
keep as rgba for now now we also
obviously have like a cpu side buffer
which represents like the data of the
actual image and that buffer is called
image data so we need to also take that
with us so we're going to come over here
and grab image data and we're going to
put it into here and this is also
something that obviously we'll need to
get like initially created over here and
then resize as well so let's go ahead
and delete it and then we're going to
basically just recreate it like this and
set it equal to width times height now a
few notes here obviously this actually
doesn't need to be called if we're not
resizing the image so even though this
does have that check i'm going to add it
again here and we're not going to call
it if it doesn't need to resize but
basically if image get width equals
width and
image get height equals height so in
other words if the image is already the
right width and height if it's the
correct width and height then we'll just
return if there is an image as well so
if there's no image it will still create
a new one obviously because there is no
image in the first place however if if
there is an existing image it will exit
out of this function if uh if there's no
resize necessary so we'll just say no
resize necessary
otherwise it will resize the image then
jump over here delete the image data and
then recreate that image data as well
now if image data is null as it will be
for the first time that's fine this will
do nothing and that's perfectly okay
whenever there's like a delete null
pointer going on i always feel the need
to explain it because some people still
don't understand that it's totally valid
to do that and you don't need to do
stuff like if
if image data delete it or anything like
that because the delete operator will
actually free which it will eventually
call that that does that check for you
okay so we now have an image so render
uh i might actually drop this down just
because
that's the order that they're going to
get called in so let's go ahead and
basically move our image generation code
that we have at the moment into that
renderer class to make sure that
everything's working as we expect so we
can delete the image from here and in
fact replace it with just a renderer i'm
going to go up here and obviously
include our renderer class that we just
created
that will already be obviously
instantiated with the default
constructor the only thing we need to do
is in render we need to call render
resize as that comment says with the
width and the height and then we just
need to call render a render
and that is it so none of this needs to
be done
this is our new like rendering code that
i'm going to take and put into the
render function so that's what we're
what we're dealing with here let's go
ahead and
grab the image width and the image
height and then random
let's come over here grab the random
class we don't need that there anymore
and we'll just include it over here this
is going to be walnut random so that's
our image data and then obviously to
actually set that into the vulcan
texture we also need to call image set
data which we will do after we after
we've gone through and set that uh cpu
side buffer filled it with our random
pixels
um yeah and then we can keep last render
time okay so this this stuff now becomes
basically if renderer
get final image as we'll call it so
let's go back
to the renderer i'm actually going to
call this final image and not image the
reason being that um it's possible that
we're probably going to have more than
one image in like our kind of render
pass pipeline because we might do like
some post processing so um for that
reason i'm just going to call it final
images so that it's clear that this
image
uh just make sure that where we've
renamed it everywhere because that this
this image is in fact like kind of our
final buffer after the rendering is
complete that's like the final resulting
image that we want to probably take and
then display so
let's go ahead and
write a function called get final image
and then that will return
final image
back in walnut app if final image is a
thing in fact i might just call this
auto image equals get final image really
should i don't know this this stuff is
new this like showing me what the types
are i don't know where that and it did
not tell it to pop up but it's popping
up now so i don't know maybe i'll
disable it although i guess it might be
useful i don't know let me know what you
guys think like for videos is this
useful to like know the the parameters
or whatever i don't generally like it
too much when i'm programming um okay so
render is undefined for some reason this
i think is size so i think we're just
missing a kelly bracket and that's
probably why okay cool so that is
looking pretty good i think that's it so
just to summarize what we've just done
is some very light refactoring we've
just moved all of our renderer related
things into a renderer class that will
also kind of act as like the the thing
that will accept our scene and we'll
output a final image that we can then
just take and um and display in our
viewport so if we hit f5 hopefully we'll
get the same result or a compile error
so i somehow got rid of that
i don't know things went things got got
weird when we started refactoring that
that part um okay cool so we've got the
same result obviously and everything is
fantastic okay so now that we've done
that let's dive back into the renderer
class and take a little bit of a look at
how how to kind of architect this part
of it a little bit better so if you've
done any kind of gpu programming like
using vulkan opengl directx anything
like that you're probably familiar with
the concept of pixel shaders or fragment
shaders and these are basically just gpu
programs that will run for every pixel
of whatever you're trying to render so
when triangles get rasterized every
pixel that is generated as a as a result
of that rasterization process
will invoke like an instance of this
pixel shader and a shader is just a name
for a gpu program so what i want to do
with this code is i actually want to
structure it to be a little bit more
like that so in other words i want us to
effectively be able to write like a
pixel shader over here in c plus plus
another great example of this is shader
toy so shader toy is a website where you
can basically write like a pixel shader
and you will get the result rendering
over here in real time so you can see
that we have like a pixel shader over
here this is kind of the format that we
write it in so you can see that we've
got it looks like it looks like a single
function doesn't have like a for loop in
it or anything however this this exact
code gets invoked for every pixel of
this viewport that we're rendering here
and an important feature of this is you
can see we can we have like a uv
coordinate now in this case the uv
coordinate if we just output the uv
coordinate alone let's add in a z value
of like zero
then this is what the uv coordinate will
look like so we've simplified it a bit
let's get rid of all the extra stuff
this is as simple as it is really what
this is showing us is a value between
zero and one across the x-axis which is
being displayed as the red channel and
then from zero to one along the y-axis
which is being displayed as the green
channel that's why you see it get
greener as you get higher up because
that value goes from zero to one and one
is full green 255 in an rgba buffer or i
should say in like a one byte per
channel kind of
integer format and then obviously with
the x axis it gets more red as you go
kind of in the positive x direction
because again it goes from zero all the
way to one and in the top right corner
where we have one on the x and one on
the y we see yellow because that's the
combination of the red and green channel
on full blast and then no blue because
we put in zero for blue and then alpha
is one this specific setup over here is
going to be really really useful to us
and it's going to simplify a lot of
things so i want to basically be able to
write this exact program as it is as it
appears here in the format it appears
here which means no four loop nothing
like that but inside our c plus boss
code so let's make that happen so what
i'm going to do is write a function i'm
going to just make it private for now
we'll call it per pixel just so it's
clear and it's going to return a uint32t
which is going to be our resulting color
now it's going to take in a glm vector
which is going to be our coordinate so
what this is going to be is essentially
the frag coordinate that you see here
now it's going to be a little bit
different because it's actually already
going to be in this format but basically
what frag quad is as an input is it's
just like the pixel coordinate in pixel
space in other words this would be like
the resolution is 1200 by 675 and so we
would have a coordinate like in that
range like the middle would be like 600
that's why you're seeing this kind of
division here where it's dividing frag
coord which is in pixel space by the
resolution which of course is 1200 by
675 to map it into like a zero to one
range so that is already going to be the
input here it's going to be already in
that zero to one range in fact we're
actually going to change it a bit later
on to be in a negative one to one range
because that is even more useful so
let's go ahead and implement this
function now as you can imagine what we
need to do now is simply call
this function from like within a for
loop like this
so that kind of our goal but from here
we actually need to work out this
coordinate so to make things a little
bit easier to understand i'm actually
going to convert this to be a nested for
loop where we're going to iterate
through the y which of course is going
to be like the outer for loop that's
going to be the height of our image here
and then the inner for loop is going to
be x now the reason why we write y on
the outside here is because we want to
be we want to be more friendly with the
cpu cache essentially so the reason why
this is important is because if you
think about the way that the buffer is
laid out in memory as we go like one
un32t forwards we're going to
essentially be going horizontally across
the image if we had flipped this then it
would be a bit weird because we'd be
skipping a bunch of memory by basically
going like a full row forwards and
that's going to actually slow down our
program because the cpu is not going to
be able to fetch that memory as easily
but anyway once we have this kind of
nested for loop where we have like the x
and y
we can easily work out what the
coordinates should be so our coordinate
is just really going to be whatever x is
divided by that total width of the image
so we can divide it here and then the
same thing for our y coordinate as well
of course but with height
now there's a fatal flaw in this and
that is the fact that these are both
integers and so when we do an integer
division here it's really only going to
be zero like for all of these so we need
to make sure that we cast at least one
of them like this to a float and then it
will do a proper floating point division
just for completeness sake though i like
to do both of them although just one is
necessary okay so we now have a
coordinate that we can pass into per
pixel and then the result here is going
to be
image data that color that per pixel
returns we're going to store inside the
image data buffer at the appropriate
location which speaking of like what is
the appropriate location because we
don't have that i variable anymore well
we can easily convert this kind of
two-dimensional coordinate x and y back
into that one-dimensional
offset of that buffer by just doing x
plus y times whatever the width is
because what this is doing is just
multiplying like the y-coordinate by
like how how big each row like
supposedly is and then just adding in
that like x column offset so now it's
the responsibility of per pixel to
actually provide some kind of color and
just to do something extremely easy
let's just set this to be magenta so
we're going to have a nice pink color
here and i'm actually going to come over
here and also include glm because we
need that since we're referencing vector
over here so let's go ahead and hit f5
and hopefully we'll see that pink
viewport and there it is now since we
did just convert our whole program to be
very much like shader toy why don't we
try this exact example so uv is already
there that's our coordinate so really we
should just be able to set frag color to
vect4 uv 0 and 1 right now we're using
integers for now as like our colors so
it's going to be a little bit different
we'll have to actually convert into that
but ultimately we're going to switch to
using floating point images eventually
i'm almost tempted to just do it now i
think we'll do it next time though just
so that we can keep things like it was
originally but to make this happen
ultimately what we would need to do is
just simply grab like the red channel
which we'll set equal to x if we just
multiply that with 255 and then cast
that
to be like a byte like that then that
will give us our red channel and our
green channel will be chord dot y and
then we need to basically shove this
into here so let's go ahead and
make something like that and then we'll
or in
g shifted left 16 or actually eight and
then
red over here so that i think should be
correct no it's black no whoops i forgot
to add in more zeros okay there we go so
you can see we get the same result it's
actually flipped upside down though so
you can see that that kind of black area
is over here and the yellow area is over
here now the reason for that is actually
to do with how i am gui displays our
image so if we go back to here what i'm
actually going to do is add one more
parameter here which was originally
optional and that is the uv 0 and uv 1
parameters and what i'm going to do is
basically set maybe i'll just drop this
down so it's more visible i'm going to
set the uv 0 to be 0 1 instead of 0 0
and the uv 1 to be 1 0 instead of 1 1.
so basically what i've done is i've just
reversed the uv coordinate of the y
axis here so that v of the uv has now
just been inverted basically and that
will flip our image now there's a bunch
of different ways that you can flip this
image to be honest you could you could
change so many things but this is just
the easiest way to do it and that's what
i usually do okay so if we run this
again now you can see we have a result
which perfectly matches what we actually
see here and we also should be able to
resize if that's something i didn't
actually check and you can see that that
also obviously works and
gives us kind of our expected range of
colors here so that is really really
important stuff because
this kind of coordinate system that i've
just shown you here and also this
function here which we can use to render
things per pixel
this is going to form the basis of how
we actually decide where to shoot out
our rays like from the camera to see if
they intersect with our sphere which is
what we're about to do so now things are
pretty simple we have the coordinates
and we're able to run some calculations
for every single pixel which makes up
our viewport so this is now
where the math comes back in so this is
the math that we did in the last episode
as a quick recap what we know is that
the equation of a circle is over here
here it is the equation of like a ray is
this thing over here and we can
basically substitute this into this to
do all of this math and more or less get
like this final final equation before we
actually substituted some some real
values to see if we could actually get
our array to intersect with our circle
so if you haven't watched that math
episode then definitely watch it i'll
have it linked up there but also if this
kind of math interests you and if you
want to learn more then i can't
recommend anything better than the
sponsor of this video and this ray
tracing series brilliant so brilliant is
an amazing website with lots of
different courses on various stem topics
and their math courses are literally the
best i've found so far on the internet
and the reason for that is because
they're extremely engaging interactive
and practical they don't just throw
information at you have you watch videos
do all that stuff they actually give you
like interactive controls to play with
so you can visually understand how stuff
works which i think is so important for
the kind of math that we're doing i mean
we're literally using math to like to
create a ray tracer like we're using
math to create images like that is like
the most visual thing ever and to be
honest like pretty much all math is like
that it's just that a lot of platforms
and a lot of different courses out there
they don't they don't fully take
advantage of this fact and me being like
a very visual learner i just think that
that's by far the best the best way to
learn they've got lots of different math
courses which cover pretty much every
inch of what we're going to be doing in
this rage racing series and these are
all just really high quality courses
these calculus courses for example
benefits so much from this kind of
visual interaction brilliant also have
plenty of courses on other stem topics
so if you're interested in like computer
science data structures just general
science as well and the applications of
that lots of stuff there to check out
and speaking of checking it out you can
get started for free by just going to my
link in description below but brilliant
have also been nice enough to offer the
first 200 of my subscribers 20 off an
annual membership all you have to do is
go to the link description below and
sign up so go ahead check them out see
if there are any courses you're
interested in huge thank you as always
to brilliant for sponsoring this video
okay so once you have
brilliant it up and you've also gone
back and watched that previous episode
of the ray tracing series and you
understand all of this
it's finally time to take these weird
equations and put them into c plus plus
so where do we even begin with that well
okay let's kind of break this down
because there are a few differences
between the equations and what we're
actually doing here first of all i did
mention that we of course did the math
in 2d whereas over here with our ray
tracing we're going to be obviously
doing this in 3d now the difference is
so small again that it really doesn't
matter we just add in that extra z axis
the z dimension so what we need to do
here is fairly simple we need to take
this equation this bx squared plus by
squared t squared plus 2ax this equation
over here and then just just substitute
the values the same way we did here with
actual like variables and then we can
use this quadratic formula to solve this
equation just like we did on paper but
we can obviously just do this like nc
plus plus so the first thing i want to
do is just write out this equation as
like a comment over here just so that
it's clear what we're doing the only
thing that we actually already
substituted here was this -4 which if
you remember was the radius squares i'm
going to leave the radius squared alone
and we have this which as you can see is
exactly the same equation as we had on
paper now there is one thing we can do
to simplify it very very slightly and
that is the fact that you can see that
there's a two at the front of both of
these terms so what we can actually do
is remove it from there and just kind of
take it out like this we'll just do this
here to simplify the actual simplest
code a little bit so now that we have
this remember t is what we're solving
for that is going to be the distance
along that ray we have all of these
unknown variables now the only real
unknown variables we have are a and b
and r that's it so what is a
a is going to be our ray origin which
going back to our math we know that from
that ray equation a plus bt is what we
kind of define these variables as a
would in fact be the origin of the ray
and b would be the direction of the ray
so a is the ray origin b is the ray
direction r is the radius of this sphere
or circle doesn't really matter though
and t is like the hit distance we'll
call it so now all we have to do is fill
these in so let's go ahead and do that
now i'm going to name these variables a
b and c just like they appear in the
quadratic equation so if we go back to
the quadratic equation and specifically
like the quadratic formula we have this
kind of a b and c inside the quadratic
formula and a b and c obviously they map
to the actual values the actual
coefficients of the different parts of
this quadratic equation so the
coefficient of t squared is a the
coefficient of t is b and then finally
that constant term here is our c term so
that's why i'm i'm going to name these a
b and c so in other words this is going
to be a
this is going to be b
and then this is going to be c so what
is a a is b x squared plus b y squared
now what you see here
is just x and y there's no z because we
were doing this in terms of a circle but
that's how you add z it's just an extra
term there like wherever we had x you
can see that we obviously split
everything up by x and y right we have x
and then we have y we have x and then we
have y we have x and then we have y well
z is just like an additional term there
so what that means is that what this is
going to be here it's going to basically
be the ray direction like squared so
multiplied with itself and then all like
summed up together
so the first question we have then is if
we really do want to figure this out
like what on earth is going to be that
right direction and this is where we're
going to talk about how we should raise
out from the ray origin in the first
place now because i wanted this episode
to be kind of not too long we'll say i'm
not going to spend a huge amount of time
talking about how to shoot raise out all
i'm going to tell you is that if we have
our camera over here we can say that
this is just at like 0 0 0 doesn't
really matter
then all we have to do to calculate
array per pixel is effectively just use
this coordinate that we have but
remember it's a bit weird because the
current way that the coordinate is set
up it goes from zero zero to one one
which is a little bit weird if you
consider that to be like your direction
if this is our camera here and we're
looking kind of along the same axis that
it's looking at it means we'd kind of
shoot all of our arrays this way and and
nothing would kind of go around right so
what we can do is remap these
coordinates to be from negative one to
one rather than being from zero to one
and we can do that really really easily
when we figure out this coordinate what
we can do is just multiply the
coordinate by two and subtract one and
of course that will just remap it from
being from zero to one
to being from negative one to one and
that will kind of make sure the zero is
kind of down the middle and all these
other rays kind of go out
out along like different sides now for a
lot of reasons this is not really the
final solution that we'll stick with but
it's a really easy way to just get
started and it will totally work we
could normalize that as well if we
wanted to make sure that they're all the
same length because obviously at the
moment they won't be so what that means
for us here is this coordinate really is
our ray direction so let's get started
implementing this equation so it's going
to be coordinate x
squared plus coordinate y squared plus
coordinate z squared because we are in
3d space but wait you say that's a
vector so how do we deal with this so if
we go back to what we drew here what
we're kind of looking at here i mean
this is a 2d image so of course it's
easy to just deal with two kind of
dimensions two axes but if we picture
this being like the actual coordinate of
each pixel on the viewport if we were to
like obviously rotate this onto its side
so not this this kind of whole thing
this plane gets rotated 90 degrees onto
the side it would just look like that so
these rays all at the moment kind of
just they have no depth to them
obviously what we want to do is we want
to kind of shoot them
that way so the camera is facing a
particular direction
and we want to shoot the rays that way
so
apart from being all across this area we
want them to actually have depth so that
you know if we do rotate them if we
rotate this view like this we actually
see them have depth like that so the way
that we can do that very easily is just
by adding a z-coordinate adding a z-axis
to our ray and then like setting it to
like one or negative one depending on
which way we define our forward to be
now for this example it's actually not
going to matter if it's positive one or
negative one not gonna matter at all
we're going to just use negative one for
now just because that's a if you're used
to like opengl that's a very kind of
common way of thinking about your
forward direction and really this comes
down to whether you're dealing with a
right-handed coordinate system or a
left-handed coordinate system but again
for now we're not going to care about
any of that what we're going to say is
that our three-dimensional ray direction
is going to be coordinate dot x
coordinate dot y and negative one so
there's that negative one on the z and
then obviously these are going to also
be between negative one and one and then
if we want that to be a unit vector we
can normalize it
now this is not going to matter for now
either so we'll leave that off for now
just so that you can see the result okay
so now we're obviously going to change
this to be our ray direction now this is
looking pretty big and if you've been
paying attention to your your vector
math you may have noticed that what
we've written out here is just the dot
product of ray direction with itself so
we're squaring each term and then
summing them all up to get a nice float
so we can rewrite this as just being glm
dot ray direction and ray direction just
like that and that's it that's the same
thing and you can see over here we're
also going to have another dot product
but this time with the ray origin but
we'll get to that eventually so this is
our a term now that's it it's just ray
direction dot ray direction that's the
kind of a coefficient of
our quadratic equation now let's move on
to this kind of b coefficient so what's
this going to be so flow b is going to
be 2 times ax bx so what is this this is
the array origin x times the ray
direction x
plus the ray origin y times the ray
direction y and then obviously it's
going to be the same for z so this is
also a dot product because we're
multiplying each component of a with
each component of b and then summing
them all up so this is just going to be
the dot of whatever a is which is our
ray origin which we haven't really
defined let's define that
again i'm just going to make it zero as
i did in my diagram it's just going to
be reorigin dot ray direction
and that's it that's our b so simple and
then c is going to be this last part
over here which is going to be the ray
origin
dot itself
but then we're going to subtract the
radius squared so let's go ahead and
define a radius for our sphere i'll just
set it to 0.5 so we basically have like
a one unit diameter sphere and then we
should be able to sort this out so this
is going to be glm dot the ray origin
with itself and then we're going to
subtract the radius squared so we'll
just do radius times radius that is our
entire quadratic equation written out
here ready to be plugged in to the
quadratic formula so that it can
actually be solved so what we'll do
today is we'll just focus on the
discriminant which remember should be
enough to see if we actually intersect
the sphere or not it will tell us if
there are any solutions so that part is
b squared minus 4ac so let me just write
this out b squared minus 4ac so let's go
ahead and calculate it here discriminant
so b squared is obviously going to be b
times b
minus 4
times a times c
that's our discriminant and so guess
what based off of this we can now check
to see if it's greater than zero then
there are solutions if it's greater than
or equal to zero there's at least one
solution and then if it's less than zero
there are no solutions so we can now use
this to return a color based on what the
discriminant is
right so in other words if the
discriminant is greater than or equal to
zero
then we can return
let's say that magenta color
otherwise we can return
just black i guess so black will be our
background and then if we hit the sphere
we should see that magenta color and
that is it let's see what that looks
like okay so we just get a solid pink
viewport right which tells us that we're
hitting the sphere
i mean i kind of maybe would have
expected to see a sphere in the middle
i'm not sure why i would have expected
that just i would have right but if you
think about it this actually makes
perfect sense because where is our ray
origin zero where is our sphere origin
zero so what's actually happening is
we're shooting rays out from here
and then we have this sphere that's here
so we're basically inside the sphere and
as we hit this of course we're hitting
it this entire sphere fills our viewport
so what we need to do to see the kind of
image that we were maybe expecting which
i don't know about you guys but i was
expecting to see something like this
with the sphere in the middle we need to
obviously move this sphere we need to
translate it back along the negative
axis the negative z axis back in 3d
space so that it doesn't fill our our
camera's viewport alternatively we could
of course just move the camera back so
let's go ahead and try that let's keep
the x and y of the camera at zero but
let's move this back maybe like two
meters or something like that and
negative two of course would be moving
it forward just like in the direction of
our ray so let's go ahead and set this
to positive two because that will be
kind of moving it back remember forward
is negative z and look at that we have a
sphere we have ray traced a sphere
amazing hopefully this has shown you
guys just how cool this kind of
practical application of math really is
because again we've gone from literally
like having this stuff on paper right to
being able to write it out
programmatically
per pixel and actually
draw this image and this is just the
beginning because remember what we did
on paper then later is we actually
solved the quadratic formula to work out
the exact location of the hit along the
sphere because at the moment it kind of
looks like it could just be a circle
it's not we've obviously used that kind
of z uh dimension as well this is
actually all being calculated in 3d
space this is in 3d it's just it's very
it's flatly lit so we can't tell so what
i want you guys to do for homework is go
in and see if you can solve the rest of
the quadratic formula then you'll get
the actual like ray hit distances see if
you can work out the 3d coordinate of
everything and maybe even figure out
like the normal of the sphere and for
bonus points see if you can apply some
shading to it to see that it is in fact
in 3d now this way of doing things has
like a bunch of flaws obviously and like
one of them is if we resize this
viewport you can see that it gets
stretched why because obviously there's
no concept of like aspect ratio or
anything we're still in that zero to one
space both horizontally and vertically
and by zero to one in negative one to
one so clearly we need to account for
like the the width of our viewport for
the aspect ratio of our viewport to kind
of not send raise out so that could be
another little homework assignment for
you but yeah this is the beginning this
is the beginning of being able to
raytrace an image so let's go ahead and
clean it up a little bit i'll get rid of
this stuff i did say i would show you
the kind of redirection normalization
but you're not going to be able to tell
the difference here it's going to look
exactly the same as you can see so it's
not really necessary it's just something
that mathematically to me seems like it
should be but for this specific thing
it's not going to be necessary when we
start getting into actually solving the
quadratic formula
then obviously the direction and the
actual length of that directional vector
is going to determine these t values and
all that stuff so it is a good idea to
normalize it potentially for some things
if you need accurate hit distances but
uh you know for just
drawing this kind of part of it it's
absolutely fine so yeah that's the final
code it'll be up on the github page so
feel free to download it and run it on
your computer and play around with it
another thing you could do as well by
the way is you can see that the equation
of a circle actually has this kind of a
and b
which is the origin of the circle or
origin of the sphere so see if you can
maybe move this sphere around we can
obviously move the camera around that's
just the right origin but of course it
would also be like useful to be able to
move the sphere around so see if you can
work that part into the equation as well
but other than that that's that's it
that's the beginning of our ray tracing
journey we finally actually used ray
tracing to draw something on the screen
so very very exciting stuff hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button next time we're basically going
to actually solve the quadratic formula
and see what we can do with that
information and add some shading so that
we can actually like see the form of our
sphere and we'll move on from there
thank you guys for watching don't forget
to check out brilliant using my link in
description below and i will see you
guys next time goodbye
you